qui aurait cru qu à cinq ans on pouvait
passer la zamboni
c'est ce qu'a fait le petit nicolas qui
a de son père à polir leur patinoire
maison la vidéo publiée sur facebook par
martin à lens dimanche dernier a tiré
plusieurs regards dont celui de la ligue
nationale de hockey
hier la lnh a publié la vidéo sur ces
réseaux sociaux et depuis le jeune
garçon et sa adam boni ont été vues plus
d'un million de fois c'est incroyable on
pensait jamais que leur piste est très
juste pour faire défendre mais la
légende partout qui nourrit mais qui
m'envoient des messages que je connais
même pas qui vit me disent ouais c'est
une femme c'est ingénieux fils à sa part
le monde
comme plusieurs familles de la région
il a fabriqué une patinoire pour eux
mais il a décidé d'en faire plus
en modifiant les camions de son fils
pour créer une femme venue le garçon
nicolas les fossés et commençait alors
qu'ils avaient jugé cette pratique avec
l'équipe de crédit sud il voulait jamais
il voulait jamais sortir se déshabille
avant que les harmonies finit de façon
tour martin souhaite démontrer que
malgré la pandémie
il est possible de créer des activités
qui font du bien et nicolas est ce que
tu es content que c'était une belle
patinoire
oui est-ce que tu joues beaucoup comme
une fois par semaine les jours oui est
ce que tu aimes seul un boni quant à
nicolas il a déjà des ambitions pour sa
patinoire un joueur de rock et de la
ligue junior majeur du québec est
originaire de chez lui l'a bien
impressionné rich ont formé ici isabelle
arsenault radio-canada moncton